ALEX LEVICH: I'm
Alex Levich, and I'm
a product manager at Google,
leading one of the areas
in Android platform.
Today we are joined by
Sabrina Ellis, product manager
and director at Google.
Welcome, Sabrina.
SABRINA ELLIS: Thank you
so much for having me.
ALEX LEVICH: Tell
us a little bit
about yourself and
your background.
SABRINA ELLIS: I am director
of product management
on the Android team at
Google, and the areas
that I'm responsible for
include Android apps, location,
and context.
And just recently, I took
over the Google store.
ALEX LEVICH: Excellent.
Sabrina, tell us all about your
take on product management.
What is that role about?
SABRINA ELLIS: A
product manager, I
think the main role is really
about bringing together
all the different parts of
a team to launch a product.
You know, one key element is
really understanding the user.
And another is to
take that knowledge
and communicate it to the team.
So you're bringing together the
design team, the engineering
team, and then all
the way through when
you're moving into launch with
the QA team and the launch
team, and all of those aspects.
And a lot of the role
of product manager
is to bring those
groups together,
so that you can launch
a successful product.
ALEX LEVICH: What does it
mean to actually bring things
together, to launch products?
What do people actually
do in this role?
SABRINA ELLIS: So it starts
from just the concept.
Who are we building this for?
And really making that clear to
everybody that's on the team,
really thinking about that user,
what are their needs, how do we
fit into their lives.
I think that's the first
step of really trying
to communicate that and
make sure that everyone's
aligned on those concepts.
And then from there,
it is saying, so how
is it that we want to build
the best product for them?
And that can mean, let's
bring together the engineers.
Let's think about where
it is that we want to go.
Let's work with the
designers to say,
if this is the user
that we want, how is it
that we would design the
best user interface for them?
With all of those
things, how do we
build a product, how
do we build a road map,
and then make sure that
we're getting the best
product out to them
as soon as possible?
ALEX LEVICH: That sounds
really interesting,
but also challenging.
What's challenging about it?
Tell us.
SABRINA ELLIS: I think one of
the most challenging things
is in general in the
product management role,
the people are not
reporting to you.
So you have this role, and
you have this responsibility,
like I said, where you
are bringing together all
the ideas of what users want.
You want to highlight
what the priorities are,
what we're all moving towards.
You want to make sure that
everyone is aligned on a road
map, but you actually
don't have the authority
of any of these people
potentially reporting to you.
So a lot of it is about
influencing other people.
It's really talking about why
are these the right things?
Why is it that this is what we
want to build for the users?
Why is this the right
road map for us to follow?
And making sure that
you've thought it through
and convincing everyone
that this is the direction
you want to move towards.
ALEX LEVICH: So it's a
lot about communication.
SABRINA ELLIS: It's a
ton about communication.
That's a huge amount of the job.
It's about influencing
other people.
And you know, I like
to say that sometimes I
get the most amount of work
done in the salad bar line.
But you've got to figure
out what your own style is
and how you can convince people.
ALEX LEVICH: And
food is important.
SABRINA ELLIS: Food
is also important.
And we are lucky that at
Google, they do feed us.
ALEX LEVICH: Indeed.
Tell us about what's
exciting for you.
What gets you up in the
morning, when you go to work?
SABRINA ELLIS: I mentioned,
I think, being passionate.
I think that's one of
the key elements of being
a successful product manager.
I think you want to be
passionate about the space
that you're working in.
For me, it is technology.
It is the potential of
taking that technology
and bringing it to large
parts of the society
and actually being able
to change their lives.
ALEX LEVICH: Sabrina,
what about now?
Are you working on
anything in particular
that really gets you excited?
SABRINA ELLIS: So right now,
one of the projects that I'm
leading is called Google Fit.
We just launched last fall.
ALEX LEVICH: Congrats.
SABRINA ELLIS: And-- thank you.
And that's a project where I
think we have a big opportunity
to really change people's
lives, hundreds of millions
of people's lives, in fact.
Right now, we know
people carry their phones
with them every day.
We know that we also
have the opportunity
to take those phones that
they're already carrying,
take the sensors
that are in them,
and make those into
fitness devices
without them having
to spend more money,
or really change their habits.
So with that data, we hope that
we can help people understand
their own fitness
and how they might
make small tweaks
in order to improve
their overall well-being.
And what gets me
up is we can really
help improve the lives of
almost a billion people.
And I think that
potential is something
that's just really exciting.
ALEX LEVICH: It is.
It's actually already
changing my life,
because I want to do more and
more steps using my Android
watch.
SABRINA ELLIS:
That's great, yeah.
ALEX LEVICH: True story.
SABRINA ELLIS: I will
admit, I feel a lot of guilt
as well when I see my stats
at the end of the day.
ALEX LEVICH: Well, thank
you, Sabrina, for joining us.
It was a pleasure having you.
SABRINA ELLIS: Thank you
so much for having me here.
ALEX LEVICH: And thanks,
everyone, for watching.
This is product management
with Alex Levich.
Stay tuned for upcoming
episodes and subscribe
to Women Techmakers'
YouTube channel.
[MUSIC PLAYING]